[Music]
architecture was a way for me
to create something i want to create a
new scenery
and the environment in my work not just
to create the products
i wanted to create a new world
[Music]
every time i travel i look for
inspiration for new space
cenote in mexico is like an entrance to
another world
i imagine it as an extremely deep and
dark world
[Music]
my starting point is to research the
natural characteristics
of the environment of each place i want
my work
to blend into the natural scenery
[Music]
the delicate sense japan has given me is
a very big influence for me
i try to express value in the pure way
i don't want to just focus on the one
goal but
create many different kind of the
futures
i take no shortcuts but move forward
little by little
[Music]
for me mom made things happen same
meaning
as natural things because human being is
also one of the nature
[Laughter]
[Music]
looking from the underwater to the
bright surface
it is like a seeing earth from the
universe
[Music]
you